[Music]
foreign
so we're talking about linear
differential equations with forcing so
instead of just a homogeneous
differential equation which is what
we've mainly been talking about up until
now lots of times our system our
differential equation system of interest
is being actively forced by some
external disturbance or by some control
input so for example you know we derive
the equations of motion for a mass on a
spring
attached to some rigid wall or some
rigid mounting and we have derived the
equations of that kind of isolated Mass
on a spring
what if I put an external force on the
base I move the base up and down at some
rate or I do something like that that
would constitute an external forcing or
an external control or disturbance and
that would give rise to an inhomogeneous
differential equation with this forcing
term
so huge amount of applications for every
unforced differential equation there are
infinitely many ways you could force it
and so this really opens the doors to
things like control theory and solving
for a broader class of Dynamics
in the last lecture I showed you how to
solve this this home inhomogeneous
equation with the method of undetermined
coefficients which is pretty easy but
also a little bit limited now I'll show
you method two the variation of
parameters it's a little bit Messier a
little bit trickier but it will be much
more generally applicable to a wider
range of forced differential equations
this F of T does not have to be one of
those linear building blocks in
exponential function or a sine or a
cosine it could be kind of any nasty
function you can write down and you can
use the variation of parameters in fact
the coefficients out front of these
terms could be polynomials of X
themselves or functions of X and you
could still solve this using variation
of parameters so I'm going to jump in
I'm going to use this simple example
just because it's easy to make
everything work in this example but you
could do this for a more general f of T
if you like okay good so um the idea of
the variation of parameters is basically
to take your homogeneous solution so if
we go down here the solution to our
unforced homogeneous equation is just a
sum of two exponential functions where
the minus one and minus 2 here are the
solutions of our characteristic
polynomial okay so so these are the the
two fundamental solutions that solve
this differential equation and so any
linear combination is also going to be a
fundamental solution is also going to be
a solution and so what the method of
variation of parameters does is it
replaces these constants with functions
U of T U one of T and U2 of T and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say x of T is equal to instead of these
constants we're going to say it's U1 of
t
e to the minus t plus U2 of t
e to the minus 2T and we're going to
plug this into our differential equation
in blue here and we're going to solve
for those functions U1 and U2 of T that
satisfy this inhomogeneous forced
equation so there's a lot
of alarm here these are arbitrary
functions you want in U2 they can be
anything at all and so we'll we'll
hopefully get some conditions on these
that allow us to satisfy this equation
Okay so so as always what we're going to
do is compute a first derivative and a
second derivative and then plug that
into this equation and try to see what
cancels okay
so x dot is pretty simple x
but because U is a function of T and e
to the minus t as a function of T we're
going to have to use the chain rule here
and so we're going to get that this is
minus U1 I'm going to drop of T just
assume it's a function of T it's minus
U1
e to the minus t
I'm going to write it over here Plus
U1 Dot
e to the minus t
so these are the two terms that happen
when I take the derivative of this I get
uh the the first term times the
derivative of the second which is minus
E to the minus t so this is minus U1 e
to the minus t plus the derivative of
the first term times the second term
that's plus U1 dot e to the minus t and
I'm going to do the same thing for this
term here so that's plus the derivative
plus U2 times the derivative of the
second term is minus 2
U2 e to the minus 2T
plus the derivative of the first term
times the second term is U2 dot e to the
minus 2T notice that I basically you
know using the chain rule I got these
two terms and using the chain rule for
this I got these two terms and I split
them so all of the U dots are over here
now again we have a lot of degrees of
freedom in choosing U1 and U2 we they
are completely our
um invention and and uh our our artifice
to solve this equation so we can plug in
anything we like for this U1 and U2 as
long as it does the job of satisfying
this equation
and to make my life easier in The Next
Step what I'm going to do is I'm going
to choose I'm going to say I want my U1
and U2 to satisfy
that this adds up to equal zero
now at this point you should be saying
to yourself well how on Earth do you
know that you can satisfy that you can
find a U1 and a U2 that not only solve
this equation but also have this
condition here and my answer is you
don't know yet but take my word for it
this will work out so this is an
assumption or an onsite so we're going
to choose a U1 on U2 so that this is
true but it's still there's a lot of you
one in U2 that satisfy this and so we're
going to then you know still have
degrees of freedom to let them uh
solve this equation okay so we're going
to you know assume that this is true and
generally speaking in variation of
parameters this is a good assumption and
this will help us down the road
at the end of the video if you're still
confused you should come back to this
assumption and really puzzle with
yourself did we violate this with any of
the further steps that are about to come
is this going to be true for any forcing
like maybe instead of writing down a
specific forcing write down a generic
forcing and see if you can work out you
know does this work for an arbitrary F
of t or are there cases where this is
not going to work okay but for now this
is a fair assumption and then we're
going to take the double derivative of
this again so X double dot
uh and using the same basic chain rule
I'm going to get something like
uh again you one e to the minus t
plus 4 U 2 e to the minus 2T
minus U1 dot e to the minus t minus
two U two dot e to the minus 2T
okay no big deal that's fine and I'm not
going to make that same kind of
assumption on this term I'm going to let
all of these terms stay and I'm going to
group this I could group this if I
wanted into something like U1 minus U1
Dot uh e to the minus t
plus 4 U 2 minus 2
U2 Dot
e to the minus 2 t Okay so that is my X
of T my x dot of T and my X double dot
of T assuming that I've relaxed these
being constants into being arbitrary
functions or almost arbitrary I want
this to be true and now I'm going to
take these three equations and I'm going
to plug them into my inhomogeneous
forced equation set that all equal to
whatever F of T is and I'm going to
solve for conditions on U1 and U2 that
have to be satisfied for this blue
equation to be satisfied
okay so that's what we're going to do
now so now we're going to solve this
equation with those X's
so
um
I'm just going to do it so we're going
to say you know like what is X double
dot Plus
3 x dot Plus
2X
specifically using these Expressions
here
and I'm actually going to group all of
my e to the minus t and e to the minus
2T terms so I'm going to write this as a
big thing you know e to the minus t plus
another big thing e to the minus 2T
that's going to equal
um
Okay so
X double dot
is this one so that's a
U1 minus U1 Dot
oh God this is going to be a mess okay
um I'm not going to skip steps this will
be a disaster if I try to if I try to
skip steps here let's just let's just
plug it all in and then collect terms
okay
um okay so this is going to be X double
dot is all of this stuff so it is
um
U1 e to the minus t minus U1 dot e to
the minus t
plus 4
u 2 e to the minus 2T
minus 2 U 2 dot e to the minus 2T that's
my X double dot term
plus three
x dot so that's Plus
three times this stuff which is
a minus three okay because plus three of
a negative number is minus three so
minus three U one e to the minus t
um minus six
U two e to the minus two t that's this
term here plus 0 because I made this
assumption okay that's my X double dot
plus three x dot
plus 2X so that's Plus
two
U one e to the minus t plus 2 U 2 e to
the minus two t and of course we know
that all of this stuff equals
are forcing e to the minus 3T maybe I'll
just keep that in blue at least for the
moment you know equals e to the minus 3
T good
and so now I'm going to rearrange and
group this stuff
um and I'm going to basically keep what
am I going to going to keep I'm going to
keep all of my dots
separate
and I'm going to keep everything that's
multiplying a um
a
um
well you'll see let's see so let's uh
this equals
I'm going to collect all of my e to the
minus t terms e to the minus t times uh
U1
minus 3u1
plus 2 U1
it's all of my e to the minus T's
plus my e to the minus two T's
that's going to be 4 U2
minus 6 u 2
plus two U2
and then I also have these dots these U1
Dot and U2 chat so uh so minus
this is uh minus U1 dot e to the minus t
minus 2 U 2 dot e to the minus two t all
of that equals
e to the minus 3T
so I've just rearranged and collected
all of my terms by plugging this stuff
into this equation you can tell this is
a little messy okay but here's what gets
really cool
all of these coefficients add up to zero
U1 minus one minus three plus two is
zero so this
adds up to zero four minus six plus two
also
adds up to equal zero and specifically
these add up to equal zero like because
e to the minus t and e to the minus two
t were Solutions of my homogeneous
equation so essentially these are just
you know an outfall of the fact that I
started with a solution of my pink
equation so these add up to zero you can
convince yourself that that's kind of
always going to be true
and now I have this very simple
differential equation here essentially I
can ignore everything here
and this is the differential equation
that we now have to solve okay so now
this is the only equation for U1 and U2
that I need to solve
um is this equation here so that's the
last step so this is a lot of steps so
far we as we took our homogeneous
solution and relaxed that these are
constants into functions we took all of
those derivatives making this assumption
here to make our lives easy and then we
plug that into our inhomogeneous
equation we find that some stuff cancels
and this is the last equation left so
now we have to we have to satisfy this
so essentially this is a condition that
has to be true
and this is a condition that has to be
true so these are the only two
conditions on my U function and this is
enough information to uniquely solve for
U1 and U2 that's that's kind of where
this came from now we're going to use
use this information
okay
um
well goodness gracious Let's uh let's
get at it
um so I'm going to use this equation and
I'm going to say
U1 dot e to the minus t
plus U2 dot e to the minus 2T equals
zero that's one condition
and that's going to tell me that you two
so like move you on over this
essentially implies
that U2 Dot
equals minus U1
dot e to the positive T
you can convince yourself that if I
literally took this and plugged it in
for U2 I would get you know I would get
e to the minus 2T times e to the t is e
to the minus t and I would get a minus
U1 Dot and so this term and this term
would cancel for this U2 so that's so
this actually was not only convenient
here but it gave me information about
how these two are related that I'm now
going to use okay so that's one
condition
let's call this uh condition one and
let's call this condition two
so condition one gave me that
information and now condition two
is going to give me the information that
um how do I want to do this I'm going to
say this is um
minus U1
dot e to the minus t
minus 2 U 2 dot e to the minus 2T
equals e to the minus 3T that's this
this condition
and that's going to imply I'm basically
going to plug in my my expression here
for U2 as a function of U1 I'm going to
plug that in here and now I'm going to
get something that's only a function of
u 1 okay and maybe I'll do it over here
so I don't feel cramped
um
and so now I'm going to get an
expression just in terms of U1 by
plugging this in here and that's going
to be U1 dot times
uh minus E to the minus t
Plus
2
e to the
oh my goodness e to the T times this is
e to the minus t plus two e to the minus
t
all of that equals e to the minus 3T
like you can slow down or pause and just
convince yourself that if you plug this
in for U2 dot this is what you get
and so now things are actually looking
pretty easy it got it got hairy for a
while now it's getting easier now we
have U1 Dot times this is these add up
to just a plus e to the minus t e to the
minus t equals e to the minus three T so
of course I can multiply both sides by e
to the plus t
and that gives me U1 dot equals e to the
minus two t
good which means that
is a lot of implies here there's a lot
of steps on steps on steps this implies
that U1 of T equals uh like minus one
half e to the minus two t plus
a constant okay this is just I just
integrated this expression I literally
integrated both sides of this to get U1
of T equals one negative one half e to
the minus two t plus a constant an
integration constant
and again because we use this condition
this is guaranteed to satisfy this and
this it also satisfies our our forcing
term here so that's for U1 I have to do
the same thing for U2 maybe I'll do this
in Orange and so similarly you know U2
dot equals minus U1 dot e to the plus t
uh so that equals
U1 dot was e to the minus two t so this
is going to be minus E to the minus
T which implies that u 2 of T equals e
to the minus t plus another constant
constant 2.
okay
and so now
I have U1 and U2 and all we have to do
the last step is we just literally plug
them into this expression and we're done
so what color haven't I used recently
I've used all of my colors
um maybe I'll just do pink
so I literally take U1 and U2 and I plug
them into this expression here and we're
done so X of t
equals
okay this equals
minus one half
e to the minus two t plus a constant one
times e to the minus t
Plus
U2 which is e to the minus t plus
another constant constant 2.
e to the minus 2T
and I'm going to multiply this all out
and we're going to find that this equals
of course e to the minus 2T times e to
the minus t is e to the minus 3T
so I have uh minus one half e to the
minus 3T
plus my constant e to the minus t and
then this one e to the minus t times e
to the minus 2T is also e to the minus 3
so that's plus another e to the minus 3
t plus my constant e to the minus two t
and then just grouping and collecting my
terms I get X of t
equals uh what is this one minus a half
is just a half so that's one half
e to the minus three t
plus a constant e to the minus t plus
another constant
e to the minus 2 t
and that's the solution
of
my forced differential equation and of
course you would find these constants K1
and K2 by taking this expression and you
know evaluating it at zero and taking
its derivative and evaluating at zero
and then solving for the K1 and K2 that
make these initial conditions work
so this was a lot more work than the
method of undetermined coefficients it
was a lot Messier because we're taking
all these like chain rules of function
so it's kind of you know we're
integrating these U1 dots and U2 dots
and we're making these assumptions so
there's a lot of steps in this but this
is also much more General this F of T
could be almost anything it doesn't just
have to be e to the you know
exponentials and Sines and cosines this
could be a really nasty function all of
this is still going to work
so maybe I'll just do one really really
quick recap the idea of variation of
parameters is that you take your
homogeneous solution with no forcing
here
you relax your constants into functions
of time
that's easy we have the power to do that
and then we're going to solve for these
functions that satisfy our inhomogeneous
solution so we go through all of the the
math and the rigmarole of computing the
first derivative and the second
derivative
but to make sure that this doesn't get
even more heinous in the second
derivative here we set this term equal
to zero and we'll use that later it
turns out this is not just convenient to
save ourselves board space it's also
convenient because we need another
condition out later
so we we plugged this in we computed the
derivative we made this assumption to
make our derivative simple then we
computed the second derivative we take
all of this information now in terms of
our homogeneous solution and these
undetermined kind of uh function U1 and
U2 we plug that into our ode we get all
of these terms
but we find that when we collect large
amounts of those terms add up to equal
zero and this is generically going to be
true again because e to the minus t and
e to the minus 2T were Solutions of our
base homogeneous solution so these go to
zero
and now we get a relatively simple
differential equation in terms of U1 and
U2 and our forcing term e to the minus
3T
so at this point we're like 80 of the
way there now what we do is we take our
first condition and our second condition
that have to be true for U1 and U2 Dot
and we just go through the motions of
solving for U2 and for U1 so you can
first solve for U2 as a function of U1
in condition one plug that into
condition two and get an expression just
for U1 in terms of your forcing you can
solve for that U1 of T by integration
and you can solve for U2 of T by
integration and when you plug those in
what you'll find is that specifically
these terms here
these terms here
end up being what contribute to your
particular solution so this term here
and here ends up you know this one and
this one those add up to give you your
particular solution x p here and you
still have your homogeneous solution so
this perfectly matches and tracks what
you would get by solving for
undetermined coefficients but this
procedure is going to be a lot more
general for a lot broader class of
forced differential equations
okay I hope that made sense that was a
fair amount of math but uh none of it
was super difficult this is all stuff
you should be you know pretty uh expert
at doing now is just a few steps to keep
track of but hopefully you can kind of
remember the major major steps here of
you know solve for homogeneous relax
those into functions whenever things get
nasty try to set them equal to zero as a
condition and then keep going through
the math all right thank you
[Music]